good morning belief nation today's
message is live your dream over to you
Conor McGregor there is no one in there
with me she's me and they're putting on
my exhibition doesn't matter the body
shape that's that's in front of me I
wore what's going on it doesn't matter
the result data I don't dwell on the on
the result you know people say predict
what's gonna happen I don't I just go in
to perform wear my heart on my sleeve do
what I do every day regardless win lose
draw whatever I show up at the gym walk
on my craft and this is it now I'll get
the show and I'm just gonna go in and
let let everything happen actually let
things flow be martial arts give me a
purpose
give me a dedication give me a drive
that I wouldn't have had otherwise what
what else I'm like on the deal this is
this is my life this the life I have
chosen I wouldn't I don't want to be
anywhere else from here huh I'm a happy
man right now I'm living the dream I
love this message because if you look at
successful entrepreneurs you look at
successful athletes you look at guys
like Conor McGregor in the UFC and you
see people who have dedicated themselves
to their craft you have found people who
have found their purpose in what they do
and Conor McGregor loves the fight and
he loves martial arts and it's much more
than just winning for him it's enjoying
again the process of what he's doing for
me I love helping entrepreneurs it just
makes me come alive when I'm talking
entrepreneurs I can do it all day long
and it just gives me energy and I think
it's so important to be successful in
whatever you do as an entrepreneur on
your career path whatever it is that you
do that you find something that you can
get lost in that when you start and it's
you know 8:00 in the morning and then
you look down you look back up at 6:00
at night you can find something that you
can lose yourself that deeply in that
you forget to go to the bathroom and you
forget to eat you're not counting down
the clocks and the when is that five
o'clock gonna come right because you
love what you're doing so much and if
you don't know what you're doing you
don't know how to find that path and you
need to explore you need to try things
you need to say yes to a bunch of things
even if it might be
scary until you find the thing that
makes you come alive and when you find
that thing it's sticking with it even
when it doesn't make any sense
doesn't make any you know logical or
rational sense when the people around
you telling you you're crazy for doing
this but it makes you come alive you
make the big decisions in your life
always with your heart and not your head
so the question they today is pretty
simple are you living your dream leave
in the comments below I'm gonna join in
the discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events press